if we switch to women what do women want
they want
also physical appearance for short-term
mating yeah phys physical attractiveness
what else uh well some cues that
represent physical attractiveness that
maybe represent health well here's this
is your
i'm learning a lot here yeah well so but
you're also asking a very interesting
question about uh what is a
controversial within the evolutionary
psychology
field right right and not totally
resolved so that's why you're on the
sixth edition of the book and there
could be a lot more questions coming
yeah i revised it every four years or so
because there's four years of um new
interesting work and so it deserves
updating but
the
traditional i should say uh
answer to your question is that women go
for good genes cues to good genes in the
short term
and
cues to resources in the long term and
this has been a hypothesis that
advocated i didn't come up with this
this one um
by
steve gangstad a former student of mine
marty haley from randy thornhill and
some other um
very smart players in the field
and um and what they used as uh
markers of good genes or things like
symmetrical features uh and masculine
features so
strong jawline high shoulder to hip
ratio
um
you know other other sorts of masculine
features
but i started to doubt this
explanation for what women want in the
short term
um because of some other
findings so for for women a lot of
short-term mating is not
one night stand mating so
but rather it's
a fair mating
so uh so if you ask the question why do
women have affairs
so let's restrict the question for the
moment
my colleagues would argue well women
have affairs because they're trying to
get good genes from one guy
while in they're getting investment from
the regular partner the husband
okay but the problem is that when women
have affairs
uh 70 plus percent tend to fall in love
with or become attached to their affair
partner
now outside what percentage 70 yeah 70
some large majority yeah
or more in contrast to men where it's
more like 30 percent of men who have
affairs
fall in love with or become attached to
their fair partner
so but from a design perspective um an
engineering perspective if you will uh
that's a disastrous thing if you're just
trying to get good genes so you're
trying to retain the investment of one
guy yeah while getting good genes
surreptitiously
from this you know guy who presumably
has one
falling in love with them becoming
attached that's that's not a feature you
want yeah it's bad engineering
yeah exactly it's bad engineering and so
and so i developed an alternative uh
hypothesis that i call the mate
switching hypothesis
which is that
affairs are one way in which women
divest themselves of a a cost-inflicting
partner or a partner who
things aren't working out well with and
it's a way to either transition back
into the mating market or to or to trade
up in in the mating market